welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins sitting in for david
today don't forget you can find me on
twitter at twitter.com
fair and balanced facebook.com
farron balanced and of course on youtube
slash the ring of fire and youtube.com
slash
fairin
balanced
the tampa bay times recently
had a phenomenal article
based on emails they had obtained
thousands of pages of emails actually
that detailed the disgusting
relationship
between fox news and florida governor
ron desantis
here's what's happening according to
this wonderful report and it's a
wonderful report because they did a good
job of digging through the data not
because it tells us anything wonderful
here
but what fox news has been doing
since the
first week after the 2020 election
is they have been
promoting ron desantis florida's
governor on their network virtually
non-stop
between that week after the election and
february of this year they had him on
their network an average of once per day
113
times
and throughout this time they were
allowing him according to the emails to
craft the narrative they were allowing
him to pick his own topics
about what he wanted to talk about on
the network
give us the talking points and we'll
just let you run with it according to
the emails
this wasn't hard hitting journalism
hell this wasn't even news of the day
this was a major the biggest
cable news network in this country
allowing the republican governor of
florida to come on anytime he wanted
to spread his propaganda
and that is exactly what he did
they made a big spectacle
earlier this year on fox news about
desantis being down here when the
vaccines were rolling out had a 100 year
old world war ii veteran getting the
vaccine fox news did a whole big special
on it and ron desantis was heralded as
the hero
of the pandemic contrasting him by the
way
with that horrible guy up in new york
andrew cuomo who lied about the nursing
home data
and what cuomo did was terrible not just
with the nursing home data as we know
but uh florida was doing the same thing
yeah according to a former former data
analyst rebecca jones
who says that she was fired from her job
for not phonying up the florida data
and she has been awarded whistleblower
status
by the state of florida because they
believe there is merit to what she's
saying
but nevertheless fox news
kept bringing desantis on
kept saying he was the leader
he was showing states how it's done his
economy was booming cases were low
everybody wanted to be ron desantis
i'm willing to bet if you ask them now
they may have a different answer
because things aren't so rosy down here
in florida anymore because of desantis's
leadership and his panderings to some of
the worst people in this state
who believe that public health issues
are really just personal policy
decisions right
you know we don't have to make a federal
case of this if i don't want to get the
vaccine and i don't want to wear a mask
that doesn't affect anybody no actually
it does
that's why it is public health
instead of personal
choice
but all along the way according to these
emails that the tampa bay times reviewed
fox news allowed desantis to come on and
spread whatever propaganda of the day he
wanted to spread
imagine if you will
let's say the daily caller
got a hold of emails
from the rachel maddow show
or you know what here's an even better
example what if you had somebody at cnn
um i don't know let's let's name this
imaginary person chris
and let's say chris
was reaching out and helping
his
brother a politician let's say maybe
governor of new york
and they were actually coordinating on
on strategy and messaging
don't you think the right wing would be
up in arms if if something like that
were to happen
obviously i'm being facetious because
yes that did happen and yes republicans
were outraged
that chris cuomo was helping his brother
embattled new york governor not for much
longer andrew cuomo
helping him craft his narrative bringing
him on his show even long before any of
that happened
to tout him as how great new york is
doing with the pandemic compared to
these other people
it's the same situation folks it's the
same situation
people are calling for cuomo to resign
from cnn or be fired from cnn and i
don't blame them
that is a massive breach of the public's
trust
but here now we have the documents that
fox news was doing the same thing with
ron desantis so where are the calls for
his resignation
huh where are the calls for the heads to
roll over at fox news
it's not gonna happen because their
audience doesn't care
their audience likes it
but i tell you folks this really truly
is no different
than chris cuomo propping up his brother
andrew cuomo it's just as deceitful it's
just as disgusting
except the cuomo's are actually getting
punished for it but desantis is more
than likely to get rewarded for it
one of our sponsors is steadymd primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video